After Watson has completed the
initial two steps of question
analysis and
hypothesis generation,
it's time to move
on to step three,
where each of the
hypotheses are scored.
In this step, Watson
computes confidence levels
for each possible
answer or hypothesis.
This is necessary to
accurately estimate
the probability of a proposed
answer being correct.
Watson will only buzz
and to answer a question
if a confidence level
for one of the hypotheses
is above a threshold.
To compute these
confidence levels,
Watson combines a large
number of different methods.
First, Watson starts with a
lightweight scoring algorithms
to prune down the large
set of hypotheses.
Recall that in step two,
about 200 different hypotheses
were generated.
An example of a lightweight
scoring algorithm
is computing the likelihood that
a candidate answer is actually
an instance of the LAT.
For the Mozart symphony question
where the LAT is "this planet,"
a candidate answer like "Earth"
would have a very high score,
but a candidate answer
like, "the moon"
would have a lower score.
If the likelihood
is not very high,
Watson throws away
the hypothesis.
They candidate answers
that pass this step proceed
to the next stage of
the scoring algorithms.
Watson lets about
100 candidate answers
pass on to the next stage.
Then Watson goes into more
advanced scoring analytics.
Watson needs to gather
supporting evidence
for each candidate answer.
One way of doing this
is through a method
called passage
search, where passages
are retrieved that contain
the hypothesis text.
To simulate this,
let's see what happens
when we search for two of
our hypotheses on Google.
Our first hypothesis
is "Mozart's last
and perhaps most
powerful symphony shares
its name with Mercury."
And our second hypothesis
is "Mozart's last
and perhaps most
powerful symphony shares
its name with Jupiter."
On Google, if we search for
Mozart, symphony, and Mercury,
we get about 900,000 results.
And we get some good results.
They definitely mention the
three words we searched for,
but Mercury is only
next to symphony once.
And there's no mention about
this being his last symphony.
Now, if we search for Mozart,
symphony, and Jupiter,
we get about 1.5
million results.
And they look much
more promising.
We see the phrase "last
symphony" a couple times
and "Jupiter symphony"
more than once.
Therefore, the
hypothesis with Jupiter
seems to be more supported than
the hypothesis with Mercury.
Now, the scoring analytics
determine the degree
of certainty that the evidence
supports the candidate answers.
More than 50 different
scoring components are used.
One example is analyzing
temporal relationships.
Consider the Jeopardy
question-- "In 1594, he
took a job as a tax
collector in Andalusia."
Two candidate answers are
Thoreau and Cervantes.
However, this algorithm
would determine
that Thoreau was
not born until 1817.
So it would give a higher
score to Cervantes.
Once all of the scoring
algorithms are run,
Watson needs to select
the single best supported
hypothesis.
Before this can be
done, similar answers
need to be merged, since
multiple candidate answers may
be equivalent.
As an example, the
candidate answers
"Abraham Lincoln" and "Honest
Abe" refer to the same person.
So the scores for these
two candidate answers
need to be combined.
Watson should not be
viewing similar answers
as competing choices.
Now, Watson is ready
to rank the hypotheses
and estimate an overall
confidence for each.
To do this, predictive
analytics are used.
To compute an overall confidence
level for each candidate
answer, Watson uses
logistic regression.
The training data is a set of
historical jeopardy questions
and all of the
candidate answers.
Each of the scoring
algorithms is
used as an independent variable.
Then, logistic regression is
used to predict whether or not
a candidate answer is
correct using the scores.
This gives each score
a weight and computes
an overall profitability
or confidence
that a candidate
answer is correct.
If the highest confidence
level for one of the candidate
answers for a question
is high enough,
Watson buzzes in to
answer the question.
In total, the Watson
system is composed
of eight
refrigerator-sized cabinets
and has high-speed local
storage for all information.
It originally took over two
hours to answer one question.
And the team had to reduce
this to two to six seconds.
In the next video, we'll see
how Watson progressed in the six
years between starting
and playing on Jeopardy,
what happened during
the game, and what
the Watson team
is working on now.